welcome back to las vegas now the
alphabet is alpha lit okay alpha lady
there's this local marquee rental cup
company that is ready to make your
celebrations even brighter and here to
tell us how is owner of alphalit heather
clark your slogan
you spell it we light it up we love that
so tell us about the inspiration um you
had to create this company what's your
story what's my story that's your story
we want to know you're a local company
woman-owned i love it there was a need
in las vegas for some more party decor
you know there were more lights
everywhere yes more lights more events
um
yeah there was a hole yeah okay and
you're feeling it we love that so what
do you guys actually provide what can we
get from you what can we rent you can
get our three foot metal letters love
this we have four foot numbers those are
very popular birthdays of course
anniversaries things like that
we also have special characters like a
heart an engagement ring is really cute
a star is my favorite okay okay um and
then some additional toppers that sit on
on here that a small v if you put it on
a last name for a wedding or
a mister and misses love that love that
okay and these are for indoor and
outdoor right what are the how are they
made why are they so sturdy
these are high quality metal they're
just standard
um
bulbs
i also have led bulbs that that work in
there as well oh cool so you can
actually do different kind of lights i
can do solid colors i can do disco
craziness i can do it all oh i see
there's a four there's a pink yeah
bright pink there's a
red white or red green and yellow
girl red green and white for christmas
where am i okay let's talk about um you
know what kind of events are you seeing
out there that people are ordering these
lights for oh name a few some people are
probably everything we do a lot of
corporate events birthdays weddings
anniversaries engagements um
school functions like proms and japanese
holiday graduation
company holiday party she lit up our
company holiday party was beautiful it
said eight news
or eight now excuse me and do you have
like a fun most memorable order that
someone asked for oh my god that you can
share i know it's vegas yeah things get
crazy
21 letters
all in a straight line 21 letters so at
two two feet each that's about 42 feet
wow
what did you do when you got that order
in whoa
well first i had to reserve another band
right
another vehicle to transport them all
and uh
but it was amazing yes i'm sure it was
beautiful and you guys not only are
giving back to us lighting up our
parties but you also give back to the
community can you tell us how you do
that uh we love to be involved we've
done events for make-a-wish
um the nevada childhood cancer
foundation the burn foundation
uh project for humanity
beautiful so you're all over town
helping us you know keep our parties
going um how can people reserve a rent
with you guys where can people find more
information instagram is a great place
to find us okay you can see all of the
beautiful work that we do yeah and get
some inspiration i'm sure some party
inspiration our handle there is uh alpha
lit las vegas okay okay no no hyphens no
periods no nothing just straight out
keep it simple
and then same thing for our website
which is where they can reserve awesome
well thank you so much heather this is
cool i'm gonna i want las vegas now
right here i know right on a daily can
we just get that rental going and it's
really wide it won't sit
julian i'll send it over to you that